continue to bash israel despite an
explosion of anti-semitic attacks in
america
jewish people targeted from coast to
coast after the recent fighting in the
middle east
democrats like bernie sanders keep going
after israel
the united states of america has got to
be leading the world
in bringing people together not simply
supplying weapons
to kill children in gaza our job
is not simply to put more and more
military
support for israel it is to bring
people together and after days of
waiting
president biden and vice president
harris are finally getting around to
condemning the anti-semitic violence
both taking to twitter to call it quote
despicable
juan do you agree with bernie sanders
that dubai
administration is supplying weapons to
kill children in gaza
i don't think they're intending to cause
violence against civilians but i think
that's the argument jesse
i mean to my mind you know we have to be
very clear here
and not confuse anti-semitism
with legitimate criticism or debate
about israeli
policies that's a separate issue that's
not it's not anti-semitic to say i
differ with israel's policies
you have debate among jewish people
including
bernie sanders about what israel is
doing how it conducts its policies
you have you know apac versus j street
in terms of the jewish american
community taking different positions
so there's nothing anti-semitic about
criticizing israel
i think that the larger issue here is
where do we go as an american people
uh with regard to this violence that
we've seen in the streets it's
reprehensible
it is to be condemned by every side i
don't care if it's
anti some violence against jewish people
i don't care if it's anti-muslim
violence i don't care if it's anti-white
anti-black or
you know those people who want to say oh
chinese people brought covet here and
they're attacking the asians in larger
numbers
all of it tears at us as americans and i
think we all need to stand together
in opposition to that kind of uh
behavior
i will wait one last thing about israel
though i think there's a generational
divide you can start to see it now in
the
poll numbers about israel that didn't
exist previously everybody
just you know wanted to support israel
they were so vulnerable
i think israel and president prime
minister netanyahu better be aware
of the fact that there are more and more
americans who are critical of israeli
policy
i haven't seen that but your point about
israel being vulnerable greg why do you
think the democrats
always root for the so-called underdog
even when the underdog is just firing
rockets into civilian territory
they could just be stupid yeah or they
could just be inconsistent uh why do you
think there's more anti-semitic attacks
going on right now
there's a dramatic uptick why is there a
rise in anti-asian
attacks a dramatic rise it's because all
violent crime is up
right all violent crime is up across the
board
we talked about this months ago it was
laughed off but
you cannot tease out specific hate crime
as something reprehensible without first
condemning all of it as a group
so this is all due to a reduction of
policing the lack of accountability when
you see
repeat felons that keep getting out no
bail it sends a message that when you
get arrested
you're going to be out on the street
before the cop is done
doing his paperwork that is a fact
some people are more important to your
answer to your question
jesse some people are more important to
the media
than others which is why the media and
the democrats respond inconsistently to
violence even when it's well documented
with words
pictures and statistics i don't know why
it's so hard to maintain a consistent
disavow of all violence
from the riots and the lootings to the
police to the january 6th
to the gang crime to the attacks on
asians to the mentally ill
attacking people on the street in new
york city if we were actually consistent
about this
none of this stuff would ever happen and
what you what you would need to do is
have a very strong
support of law enforcement that would
keep this from happening because that's
the incentive one needs
yeah katie it goes without saying that
politicians should condemn all violence
you know
we have a big headline in here that
biden and harris you know condemn this
attack on on jewish americans i mean
obviously
but we didn't always hear that last
summer
if you look at where this started um
this this implies that israel is somehow
purposely committing violence against
hamas and gaza
when the reason why they had to fight
back at all
is because hamas which is an
iranian-backed terrorist organization
sent 4 000 rockets into israeli civilian
territory with the purpose of killing
jews now in the process they've killed
israeli arabs they've killed
palestinians 400 of their own rockets
misfired and killed
palestinians in gaza civilians you had
one of the leaders of hamas on sky news
admitting that they deliberately fire
rockets
from civilian areas in gaza at civilian
targets in israel so that when israel
retaliates
they kill civilians so then they're used
for propaganda
and so when you see this overflow into
the united states with pro-palestinian
hamas supporting people attacking jews
in the streets
and they know to greg's point that
they're not going to get arrested or if
they do they'll get out of jail really
quickly and then come out and say as a
guy did yesterday
i would do it again after beating a
jewish man in the street
they know they can get away with it just
like hamas knows they can get away with
attacking israel because the
international community is going to say
how dare you be violent against hamas
when really they're just defending
themselves this is not an equal playing
field when it comes to exchanging
violence
all right pretend you're jen saki dana
i'm peter ducey and tomorrow i'm going
to say all right jen
you know the quarter billion that biden
released to the palestinians that trump
had froze
they purchased weapons from the iranians
and then use those weapons
on israeli citizens does the biden
administration regret
releasing that money so um one thing
i've never done is fallen for a
hypothetical jesse and that is what you
were trying to get me to do
i'm still not going to do that but i
would note one thing um so the squad and
progressives incur
including bernie sanders put out again
it's tweets right but they're putting
out tweets saying
that they condem anti-semitic uh
violence but they add all of them added
and the rise of islamophobia yes no so
i mean and i think we just need to be
very clear about this like where
is the data where where is the increase
like where are you actually seeing it
and
i agree that islamophobia is bad and
attacks against people because our
muslim is terrible
but we do we actually have data that
shows that that's happening the last
thing i'd point out is
that it's very important that we all
remember that
the struggles we have in this country
are not a mirror image of every place
that we look
and the issues and katie knows them very
well when you can understand what's
going on
between the um israelis and the
palestinian authority and all that
it's just it's much more nuanced and
complicated it's much more difficult
it's not just a black and white issue
and so we have to be more thoughtful
about how we talk about it and i would
say that the president and vice
president
absolutely should do more than put out a
tweet tweet
matters for blue check mark um
journalists it doesn't matter to those
who are actually on the streets fighting
nuance and thoughtfulness thank you dana
farino
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else